any thoughts about using air purifiers
to reduce the risk of catching covenant
doors
i just bought one that filters down to
0.1 micron finer than n95 masks with uvc
love you both um yeah you know this this
uh filter that we be that
we have as a sponsor as of this week um
doesn't filter to quite that i don't
remember what it is i think it might be
0.3 microns but um and it didn't test
for covid but in third-party tests it
was looking at viruses small viruses and
was filtering out viruses so
um you know the the capacity and and
some such filters are used in medical
settings as well
but uh it's not you know opening the
windows
uh regularly is
is
still definitely advised
yeah i
my guess is
the filtering is a little bit of a red
herring
viruses are very very tiny filtering
them out is not a straightforward matter
because you may not be filtering the
particle you may be filtering a droplet
right or an aerosol
they are so i think often it's the ubc
technology that is being um promoted as
as what is it may work the viruses so
the question is how well is this
designed so in other words how much time
does a if a virus gets past the
physical filtering how much time is it
exposed to the uvc
and is that sufficient to break down
something functional about it right
those are all good questions maybe that
works let's suppose you designed one
that was cruddy right in which things
passed through very quickly and it
didn't manage to catch them but
because it moved a lot of air
a it uh evaporated the
particles the droplets and the aerosols
more quickly than a static room right so
just simply moving the same volume of
air would cause those things the virus
to be
freed of its
water molecules
potentially would that have an impact
it will
disperse the air so to the extent that
there might be a coveted source in some
place and that means there's some pocket
of the room that is disproportionately
highly concentrated
right so make more uniform the
distribution right and so the point is
okay let's say all of these things are
in play and none of them are
you know more than 15 percent effective
but the combined effect might be
substantial
you know
so does having the thing in the room
working have some effect yeah yeah
probably it does yep
[Music]
you